[Music]
hello everybody happy Tuesday Chewbacca
happy Halloween everyone is dressed up
I'm no I just
I found this mask when I was like maybe
I'll do the whole stream in this matter
like don't do that I'm like oh maybe I
can get through the nightfall yeah it's
gonna be doing the nightfall weekly
update on the PC here are get to 70 yeah
I'm like 281 so for the time being as
check kind of gets filled a little bit
I'm just gonna go do so there's easy
flashpoint this week obviously so you
want to go to European dead zone and you
know do that milestone there's also the
rate is out now technically for PC so
people can start doing that I think on
console they're gonna eventually have at
10 a.m. actually is there a past 10 a.m.
so the challenge mode the first
challenge mode for consoles also well
if you guys are looking to do the
nightfall hopefully your 260 is plus
ideally if not that's on the end of the
world
and you can ascend John Luke your
gamertag battlenet gamertag
what it's worth super
actually movie yeah what's gonna do a
what do people last year I was Deva last
year bender bender Devo gender bender
diva this year she must be back yeah I
think I don't know if this is I think
Hana might be fuse up with her like that
yeah hundred percent sure on that I
didn't ask her myself but how about she
was pinching from dark stalkers oh I
know that's what I thought I don't think
she is cuz that would be a weird deep
cut okay I only you might it's more
likely just the outfit made me think for
a second that it was that well one I got
to chase loot again because there's
pretty much nothing for me to face on
during the game yeah I don't know it
feels good my fears of muscle memory and
all that stuff have there gone pretty
much I remap the few keys the only one I
don't like is this one because my melee
is now on wheel but like every now and
then when I melee accident we do the
weapon scroll Oh Renee Don wheel and I
put melee on my no no just my mouse is
like my button i always put mainly on
the side button my my grenade is q and
my melee is middle mouse but my melees
middle mouse because i think you know
overwatch I made my melee I don't know
it might not be the best flat legs
I like mainly side and then you know my
login for that I don't so it's my first
and last name sweet at comcast.net yep
that's right comcast and then it's the
normal so if you guys are curious about
power and anything like that once John
was guessing the chat I can help kind of
explain if you guys didn't already know
how did there we go
so yeah if you guys don't know what to
do I got the 280 in like a week I didn't
try this super hard so it's definitely
doable it definitely helps to be in a
clan you could actually get clam the
last or sorry raid loot last week yeah
despite not being in a not being able to
do an actual raid yet master volume is
low yes people are saying master volume
is low I think though same issue we were
having you know what it is it's probably
because I know probably because you just
what you're trying to listen to me
through a mask which is probably like
damn near impossible so you know there's
that so hopefully it's better now if you
haven't boosted us all the way you could
do that too I usually boosted us all the
way wait we'll see let us know this
should be this should be good now though
I feel like I feel like this should be
good all right look at all these buddies
here because it's easy week so
everyone's here obviously so another
trick I'll try to show you guys if it
works out I don't know if they will or
not but we'll try is you can kind of
like cycle through the public events if
you're really quick about it so if you
guys didn't know how to turn this a rope
obviously you want to kill these swimmer
things there you go that guy knows
what's up nice thing about the PC
yeah I okay so you've played a bit of PC
now as well as the beta do you feel like
this is faster than console or is it
just something in my head I feel like it
it feels faster just in general the the
speed of the game feels faster I don't
know if it's just in my head or not
because I was running on like PC versus
like running on on a console and I was
like oh this is so slow on console you
know yeah I think it's a couple factors
I think running on 60 it's automatically
just gonna see faster mm-hmm can you
like your brain yeah your movement the
fact that you can just like haptics like
speedy movement it's gonna help as well
but to see my side
a bit faster to make it father challenge
hmm if I if I had respect yeah because
if they would have done it one to one it
would be yeah so I think everything just
in general feels a smidge faster because
I know that they actually did
significant work like changes like
they're you know recoil was completely
differently which makes guns like
submachine guns way more viable yeah I
would I would love to see like a really
get all the my new changes
what if somebody made a video about dad
oh please
shadow or even like I'm a digital
foundry yes actually
no gonna pop a coin hope for the best
young Luke that that also means that
anyone that joins me assuming there is
anyone I have to join me will also get
the benefit of my little [ __ ] it's
almost I got three of coins if anyone
remembers from testing one kind of I
don't know if they do exactly the same
with the [ __ ] will affect those destiny
new here can i play the nightfall now if
I'm just level eight power level minding
no no you cannot you probably don't even
have it unlock yeah whoa it recommends
you it recommends you wonder like
straight up like not let you everything
would probably be like blood red and you
probably die and like yeah you probably
don't have access to it and even if you
do you would die immediately so I would
definitely not yeah just get through the
story first yeah there's a lot of stuff
a lot of other stuff yeah but a little
bit spare time I have been kind of just
here's attempted trick so you try to
instance into another heroic public
event like right away and hope that it's
still there and you could still get loot
from it I tried doing that on the
console but I think because the low time
x mark if you're 290 you can do the raid
as long as you have a group oh I didn't
work oh yeah 290 you're fine I think
you're really like 270 to start the raid
is good you want to be around 280 though
I think in general yeah
280 would be nice so it didn't work out
this time sadly sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't sometimes I even
try loading again like here we try again
someone suppose Lobby next lobby is
tomorrow we do it on Wednesday yes we do
have another stream when later today
though yeah that's actually gonna be
pretty cool we're gonna be having the
the best of guys come in and they're
gonna show off doom and Skyrim in VR
yeah so if you're interested in seeing
what those are like we're gonna get to
play those for cool yeah yes there was a
comment there I missed the the person
that made it but yes rip visceral
someone said that just played dead space
for the first time recently and we did a
dead space tree or well you and Mike did
me Mike to adjust it we did it right but
how it's so like weird the time they
threw the game was weird and people at
the time were like why are you streaming
it's just a night anniversary this is
weird and surprisingly relevant man
what's up Don Juan yeah so again I don't
know if you guys heard this earlier
we're trying to do then I fall this week
for the weekly reset obviously if you
guys are around hopefully I don't think
you have to be 260 but I just prefer if
you were like 260 plus just to make
things a little bit easier if not it's
not the end of the world if you want to
do that send your tag in chat to
Jonathan's go ahead
yeah I'm sure some guys tried to do at
the beginning yeah well I love where you
he's like 220 I'm like no yeah well you
just be Wolfenstein right hit me up on
ps4 I wouldn't be doing this on ps4
though I stopped doing the weekly stuff
on PC other than like raiding what like
this for the time being just because
just like I said there's stuff for me to
actually farm like I don't have
merciless I don't have like current all
there's like [ __ ] I don't I'm not max
light yeah that's the question is that
you're the only reason why I say that is
cuz all my friends aren't fused for
still they migrate so I was doing this
mainly because I figured you know pcs
fresh we were doing destiny streams you
know every week now for like 8 plus
weeks I figure there are some people
that might not have played console maybe
switch to PC or started on PC and that
we could do these weekly streams and and
help those people out I guess
was kind of the premise also I don't
know I kept staring at Assassin's Creed
origin for that a copy and I was like do
I want to play this right now sing yeah
I don't have like three like two to
three hours to get like a solid to three
hours to give it so like I ended up
playing like you know 30 45 minutes of
destiny hearing that you should play
let's see here okay here's a problem I
did not I will be honest I did not play
the new order okay and so I was actually
gonna ask you how much would I miss if I
just skipped it new order and played new
Colossus like story wise because there's
obviously it's a sequel right so sequel
and the game does have a story primer
we're like VJ like narrates like
like a cutscenes that show like what
happened in the last game so you get
thing you get the whole story if you
play this one you can kind of get that
story primer however I it is so
dependent on those characters and I like
it
outside of that story primer the game
doesn't really hold your hand in terms
of like you should just kind of know so
you could probably be buying just
getting along if you watch that opening
but I do feel like you're missing yeah
yeah and it's like those relationships
that you would have forged or bought
like gotten from playing the first one
right like it's deeper obvious actly
know what's happening because of the
story primer but you're not necessarily
going to have that emotional connection
yeah that I would wear it's like oh man
that that character like yeah like I saw
some [ __ ] already because I did the
first hour with Nick and I was like oh
that probably would be really impactful
if I like played the new order I would
recommend playing the new order so I
think it's still a really good game but
if you if you don't think you're ever
gonna play it mm-hmm
you should still play okay
yellow Sanchez I would think the best
way for you to get past 252 and at least
to the 265 soft cap is if you do public
events and try to get them to turn
heroic there's like eight versions of
the public events I showed you one of
them there which was like fill the
glimmer machines on each of the glimmer
I don't know
areas that spawn there's like three in
this one you have to shoot down the was
it what's that stupid ship called the
cabal ship the treasure or something
I'll shoot it when it shows up but if
you don't know we also made a video on
that
I think me John Luke on how to get
heroic public events heroic public
events by far the best way to kind of
level up to 265 or higher because you
get a chance at like multiple pieces of
blue gear which will slowly level you up
obviously and then you
so get a coin and then you want to
slowly turn those coins in so that you
know purples etc so that would be my
best advice in terms of getting to 265
and then I would save your milestone
your weekly milestones until turning it
until the end of the week because they
will give you here that's of your light
versus just like turning them in right
away because you don't gain as much out
of it and then also you know just do
your challenges for each planet to gain
their coins which you can then turn into
like Deborah yeah they made it easier so
PC players kind of get a little bit of
an advantage in that they're kind of
starting with
not all of them yeah the other thing too
is join a clan oh yeah yeah you're not
cross system okay so last week it's
funny like I had the benefit of the raid
in Graham the crucible in Graham and the
night ball grab those two of the three
we could have got easily on PC but the
raid one there's weird seeing Aaron with
like a raid sword win like I said the
raid has come out that's cool that if
you joined the GameSpot clan on PC you
can get yeah you would've got that C
player ps4 players are still you know
working at those pretty much the only
planning Graham that the the GameSpot
clan won't really get anymore because we
don't have the TD peers on as much
anymore is the trials at nine one but I
feel like every other one you will get
the benefit of I think that ship
thresher that's why it's called fudge
fudge don't go away
I'm probably gonna die I'm by myself her
okay I miss goodnight to her oak is
harder to do on your own at this point I
have just started accepting along with
every invitation at the beginning we
were trying to prevent it because we
only had a hundred spots you want to
make sure yeah we got all the employees
in Louise extended close friends family
joined in nice
he is a founder I have admin rights but
obviously whoa hello admins gonna accept
invites yeah that's correct
again I am looking for people that do
the knife also yellow Sanchez you're
technically high enough I guess 52 is
not terrible what I would do but see
normally my advice to you would be to
not do the knife all this early when
you're at that level but I mean if you
haven't been able to get it done then we
can try to get it done obviously oh yeah
I'm just lazy to be trials unless you do
a lot of things on console now I'm
basically waiting for I'm doing the
challenge mode stuff I still do the raid
once a week but I'm more or less waiting
for cursor to Cyrus at this point and
console personally but alright so you
kill that ship
it will then spawn a big cabal of you
that you have to kill and then you will
get your hope we put this guys kind of a
foot yeah I do
Oh God why is that dog here alright
because it's so alright if you didn't
know this during the weekly miles or a
flash point for the for the planet you
will have like extra like high-value
targets spawn on the public events so
that's why this stupid war hound this
year and he is really freaking annoying
because he actually hurts quite a bit
when you don't deal with him and because
I'm by myself I forgot she's asking if
we have a Skype no we do not
I don't mess it up it's not a
set up here yes we might have it soon in
the other studio on the other studio
yeah we're getting a new much time do I
have
I only I mean it's in 12 seconds all
right we gotta go kill the big dude try
oh yeah and that thing I mean well that
thing potentially has potential to sync
up with this room there's some
interesting stuff we could maybe do that
it's not it's not therapy some cases Oh
God
why didn't you shoot that rocket game
that's why yeah let me aback juices new
studio not new studio just new you tried
something yeah something in this studio
yeah new new hardware new hardware that
we didn't have to set up I don't know
this is so stressful now that now that I
have that room all set up I wanna stop
it what I could do with that room the
world is your oyster
yeah well within reason I should always
preface that it's like a it's like a
disclaimer like the liability guess this
creamer is just in case you know I do
whatever I want
yeah and it's like okay I'm gonna go try
doing this like parkour and get really
hurt it's like no okay no you can't you
can't do that I'm here you stupid dog
I'm hiding in the forest alright so that
was heroic hopefully good that's how
life is once you're past 270 do we get
anyone that wanted to be in that I think
most of the people on here probably
council players
oh really yeah the goob and Bob I had to
guess yeah it's a pretty it's a pretty
strong guy I could try
yes pulse grenade is okey I don't know
if someone said Opie ones are awesome
randos it's hard to try with randos I'd
have to LMG or I could I was gonna say I
could try to solo it which would be real
stressful if I would be terrible
actually cuz its prism which is not
awful but when you're by yourself you
could get blown up really easily so I'll
keep doing the milestone stuff until
someone hopefully shows up all right
hand cannons Opie uh it feels better on
PC I don't know don't know if that's
that's just me or maybe I just want to
play a different style you just have
that accuracy yeah probably
what's up Jake
because I don't think anyone is on yeah
a couple of people are saying they want
to join but TC so no because they're all
uh well you know I could grab my
playstation I didn't realize that this
was going to become an issue where there
weren't people playing the PC but I just
figured you know everyone's curious what
the numbers are yeah I'm right because
everyone I know went to the PC really
yeah all my friends had it on console
and they all switch to peace how many is
that like three four oh [ __ ] he's still
counting it's pretty good if I like it a
lot better TOC I do the way you should
have played this game okay you heard it
first yeah so I'll probably end up just
sticking with you see at this point then
yeah slowly swap over you see now unless
I need to play with like
[Music]
we get there playing pretty regularly
I'm not since I'm playing
if I can just kind of catch up to them
by the time Osiris comes out mm-hmm I'll
be fine
yeah and then you'll always have the
rewards each week yeah as long as like I
keep playing yeah I feel like I should
too and I would offer that up to the
people in chat it's just like harder to
stream that because that would be an
event like a long that's true that's a
real stressful though having a meeting
tomorrow I'll I'm on PC but only 239
power oh you should be doing this with
me right now mr. Grayson and then you
could probably level up a little bit to
like 250 something and that would be a
way to get you to deal with you the
nightfall by the way guys we are
planning on doing extra life
we're gonna do it later than Rome
usually starts this weekend however we
are so busy with big games coming out
plus yes this weekend so unfortunately
doesn't really work out for us to do it
this weekend and then the next weekend
is day of deaths that's true also we're
gonna be really busy with
oh nice Sanchez you should join me too
if you're trying to get to 265 sorry to
cut you off there girl that's fine so
we're gonna try and well know what the
weekend of the 17th last year where all
the major GameSpot across the world are
gonna join us
cool the global the global strike force
yep
so we're gonna start like kind of spread
the word from all that out pretty nice
okay it's a cool way to do it I probably
will do that I'll probably still help
out obviously but it'll be easier for me
to do something like that at home or
something I want us to have separate
teams and I wants to compete
more you asking for trouble you know
what happened man des always takes it
home she does and I feel like a lot like
I feel like there's always that thing
with donations were like a lot of people
hold off till the end and like UK had
some pretty good pretty good stuff last
year two more you know lost a lot of
hair
our current boss now chris beaumont gave
a fair amount to that cause yeah so yeah
but you never know it might raise the
motivation yeah so Grayson send us send
over your tag if you need to PM it or
something I don't know what the best way
would be maybe Twitter
buran says if you're not in a rush you
can wait obviously I think destiny
console went half price roughly a month
after ish it was I don't know if that
was like a ongoing deal or just like a
weekend deal but I saw it go down to
like 30 bucks so if you're not in a rush
I would wait but if you have some
friends playing and you want to get on
the the hype train go and do that thing
I'm sure buy a holiday maybe it'll go
down but the problem with the waiting
till holiday - is that the DLC will be
out which means you may have to buy that
- I mean like obviously you can still
have this experience you just won't have
some of this stuff that other people
have like there'll always be this
version destiny - proper of course
so we'll get Grayson and Sanchez just
anyone I mean there is something to be
said about
worked on fanbase playing that you know
a friend of mine didn't actually get
into destiny 1 until last
so taking king version was legit though
like if you didn't play destiny in that
entire time yeah good I think taking
king was a very good time to get in cuz
there a lot of quality of life fixes Oh
totally all that stuff well oh there's
gonna be a complete edition I feel like
complete edition is the new the new like
oh like a big one that's a that's there
isn't that much they could add to this
one other than some of the stuff they
decided to leave out surprising yeah
well and then you finally got a somewhat
decent storyline
I don't know mr. graison's what's the
best wait a minute I'm just trying to
think of a way of doing it like in
YouTube so that like I don't have to
give out my battlenet tag that's true we
can invite them that way who wants to
join the clan who tarik asks what is the
next franchise for history of was that
on hold again it's on hold again because
he's out this week so I'm gonna be doing
a history of Call of Duty specifically
the world war two games I'm not covering
every solitary game I'm just covering
three points ten technically wow really
yeah cuz they did a bunch of that's a
lot more than I thought they did a bunch
of side ones that a lot of people don't
remember so yeah
way more than you think but oh sure I'm
gonna be doing that but don't worry it
I'm still playing on doing Mario it's
it's late I know Odysseys already come
out so maybe about high polls will kind
of be gone but at this point I just kind
of want to just want to do it you know
winding Cove Sanchez so well get Cod
this week and then I'm gonna work on
Mario next week and that'll actually be
the last the last two for me for the
rest of here
I was very tough to compare this game to
Halo boo Ron there so like the time gap
between those releases and now is like
so far apart he wanted to say he asked
like how is this compared to teyla one
and three oh they're so different it's
very it's very hard I mean the shooting
feels
really good but also we took a different
game like halo was all about that um you
know if you've always heard it's like
shooter chess right we're like the way
each gun has a very specific use this
gun these types of enemies there's
something about the flow of halo halo
combat that was all about like what
weapon is best with what enemies and
what story it was the raid it's kind of
there
I think it's cuz you don't aren't high
enough to be no I'm 280 well maybe yes
nothing to do with it maybe they oh okay
so I know that there's an update oh I
guess Aaron's joining all right cool
sorry Greyson someone at work was like
oh there's people playing um that's
really weird that maybe okay so I know
there's an update coming out today so it
could be that maybe that updates not
around yet or it's kind of like you said
I might be just logged on early cuz last
time we had to like log out log back
just to get to trigger so it could be
that I'm kind of shocked that it's not
there yeah branch wondering more like we
talked story and gameplay since they're
both from Bungie I mean sorry for sure I
think I think destiny has a more
interesting concept of a narrative like
that your ideas for destiny I think are
more interesting than Halo but I think
their execution halo I think I'll defer
to you because I really only played halo
like halo halo for PvP and not so much
food I didn't know in an Xbox sure blue
eyes
again I do think they're kind of
different styles of shooters destiny
much more about like when we cry in the
Halos
that chess yeah I draft me which one I
prefer for Albany halo just because
that's kind of more what I grew up with
but it's a little apple juice first
I do think halo like recent multiplayer
is better than crucible because I think
crew suppose this was fine I think it's
definitely not the same almost like
unchallenged just like the sheer variety
of things you can do that game I feel
like that's me very is just like it's
fine it's very box like it's very fine X
Gaming says that they saw the rivers
ginger release later today Oh got it
ok fair enough we need to shoot that all
right
that wants to give me a shout-out for
great job on history Wolfenstein thank
you nice nice nice mm Marcela frequenter
of the streams thanks Matt
there's a way to kind of like keep doing
the smash if you can time it right
sure
so I'm saying that the combat systems
got the same between the two
oh yeah I mean okay in the sense that
you have a gun and you shoot them
halo-halo
are feel much different than okay like I
think halo very specifically calculates
like the way it incorporates in a way
that destiny I feel like doesn't
differentiate like in Halo you could
technically be anyway any enemy with any
gun but it was certainly like you want
to use this type of gun you want you
want to use energy weapons to take down
the shields shields faster right you
want to use human weapons to beat the
flood like there are certain weapons
that just kind of like universally are
designed to work better with certain
enemies and it's trying to teach you to
learn what weapons work best and like
cycle through that stuff in destiny it
doesn't matter
like any gun will be any enemy like the
difference they have is exotic nice
we'll find out later yeah yeah I
understand I don't know I again I can't
speak too much to it so I just kind of
let you talk that one true
yeah tarik saying that he's he or she is
enjoying the stream cool but he's the he
or she again is a huge single-player
driven on the game itself but not
yourself so I don't know sure with
destiny that's it's obviously one of
those games that because it is a kind of
multiplayer ask after you finish the
story you kind of need to have a couple
people on or you need it just like you
know you're that's part of what the clan
system hopefully was trying to alleviate
a little bit was you know the hope that
there are other people online that you
know you're playing with that you
hopefully if some point build a bond
with and then you can get hop on and
play with them and that kind of enriches
your experience I do have to say like
playing this game kind of solo is not
that fun like overtime you just really
have to want to better your character
hmm your self so I would say you know
obviously try to joy plan we try to meet
some people that way it obviously worked
in WoW so you know there's a bunch of
people I know that like or there have
been a bunch of people that I have met
almost like not even in real life and
like wow that became my friends of mine
you know I ended up hopping on got to
play with them so that's part of it yeah
more interesting story driven
single-player games - yep send that hot
invite in a hot invite will join saying
with any gun I was saying that the game
of school redesigned were certain guns
worth better against it oh did that not
do it
it's crazy a rocket and a pollster NATO
is not enough to blow up the ven find
that blast
you know what wait is that that's not
the gray guy right gray vain huh that'd
be so crazy if that was actually oh
shoot black
yeah Marcelle things put 35 hours into
the game and how to put it down Wow it's
a grind to go out it alone oh absolutely
yeah it you have to have the willingness
to want to do like these whoa okay so at
least public events help a little bit so
like right now like look at how many
people are here right so it makes you
feel less alone but obviously since you
don't have a direct tie to any of them
maybe that's it still feels lonely well
that's okay even if they don't like
[Music]
killing myself it's down below oh wait I
think we got it you did you got it all
right worth so now we got heroic
obviously makes a pretty big difference
again uh well actually not always that's
not always true all right you know we
can try doing we try doing the night
ball were there I'll just have to yeah I
just had to better put them into the
backpack or maybe he'll level up a bit
from this stuff [ __ ] his possible tears
we've done a couple of these now so if
he's gone a couple blues to help
all right we finished our weekly either
clan or we did the earth one no we did
okay
and we got nine XP all right so see what
level is senior Aaron he is 215 how has
he not got any upgrades I don't even
know if he has it available on his thing
what's the recommended is it 240
man yeah 240 come on Aaron don't unlock
do you even have it unlocked yeah I do
okay I did it I did it yesterday okay so
how does he how did he not get any gear
from that all right it's G G why would
it be G so I figured that out yesterday
I had to look it up the inspect or like
how to toggle a person and then inspect
I don't know how you lock on a person no
no a gun like I kinda go walk a gun like
in here there ya up now it doesn't work
and let's then click on it then you
click on it there you go I locked it
actual button don't do it cuz normally
you can just do it from you don't have
to click on the gun yeah you press a
button right thank you so I'm like how
do I do that yeah all right we'll do one
more a public event like that for Aaron
and hope like oh right the game that was
made for consoles yeah like for the most
part they do a really good job adapting
it to PC and making it not feel like a
port and then there's just a couple
stuff like that you're like alright this
is a
[Music]
don't assign to was we really like that
as well like for the most part my field
for coffee really certain menus like
there are the majority that game I think
that game is better on kacie like just
the feel of mouse and keyboard is like
so good it feels great and the
difficulty of that game feels honestly
weird with like like watching people
play with controller it feels kind of
stiff but then like there's certain
menus that like don't have a mouse
option you have to use the arrow keys to
like navigate through John Dee talking
about crucible being booty right now
because if you don't have a mighta
Orioles gift or a last hope you're in
[ __ ] out of luck I actually feel like on
PC there's been more variants however it
is the first week so maybe people
haven't unlike gotten to that meta yet
but I feel like this hand cannon seemed
better on PC if you have the aim so I
think that you'd be surprised at least
on PC now on console yes that that meta
that you just talked about is very true
and I'm sure it will change because I
think we were looking at I was looking
at stats at one point and like my toes
used like thirty percent of the time in
PvP and the next closest thing is maybe
eight to ten percent and that's Ariel's
gift and I think prosecutor was like a
close second if you guys know what I'm
even talking but basically yeah there's
like two or three guns that are
dominating in terms of like what people
are using at least I'm console now I
think he sees a little different at
least right now Flint family could just
be early and people haven't found out
about that you know original fear get
scared so this is one that a lot of
people don't know how to do this taking
plate one everyone yeah I end up
shooting it by myself a lot so hopefully
people know what to do here
some people are head and Riley Riley
Pierce's just found you guys great
stream yeah no this is not DLC this is
just the PC version we're doing the
nightfall
I wish ideals
Andrea's heading later she's got a lot
of work to do later thanks for joining
oh these people know us up okay maybe
that's what it is
nope nope fingers that's the [ __ ] really
looks excited as sh t or s I have
something cuz clearly I'm stupid here
look at your keyboard your keyboard
sighs [ __ ] this keyboard so yes I think
that's dumb though rights so dumb
because this one clearly said okay
because a lot of Erika's a lot of
keyboards don't have an arrow on the
cheating I agree I agree like I'm
staring it okay hold on just so everyone
knows what we're talking about now
mainly because I'm stick okay we have
another keyboard here but if we look at
this mechanical which is like newer and
which is probably what most people have
it says shift on it yeah I agree
I think anyways well screen 2k
resolution no we're not running at full
we're running at 1080p oh is it for
stream purposes yeah because we wouldn't
stream 2k it looks good yeah okay yeah
I'm in 1440p yeah I run the game in
1440p yes and it looks great runs and
like a walk 60 so this is what we're
playing at right now you guys curious
you pretty much got it all mostly mostly
high I mean I just left it default of
what it was all right we're gonna try
the nightfall this is gonna be a real
sketch I think for Aaron if we fail
I probably pick up Grayson so in his
asking if they can join now even in
Australia yes yes okay
Aaron camp is you're on PC Aaron can't
do it
he has to advance a milestone to unlock
it got a boot Aaron so sorry my friend
how can I join you guys without joining
your clan since I'm in one I made myself
I mean you can you can join anyone
theoretically it's just as far as access
so this remove no boot sorry
kick Aaron off I'm sorry but you're
holding me back and yellow Sanchez from
doing the right yeah okay yeah it was
him he has not done whatever is required
to do that
so who was that that was gonna that
would be Australia yeah rock rock
you need to send us your battlenet tag
I'm pretty sure you're safe if you send
it here oh you're 290 yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I like that I needs it um I'm
like 281 I'm using cupbearer because
cluster rockets ROP and I don't have a
curtain call which makes me very sad
yeah I need his PSN and then we can we
could start the show assuming he sends
it to us I'm gonna do I'm gonna do some
housekeeping while that happens because
you can you always gotta stay on top of
dismantling all these blue gloves when
are you guys gonna accept clan of course
spy after the stream or you can
technically do it from his Bungie app
right now really it's been better it's
definitely better at later goop I'm
gonna I'm realizing we gotta do this
pretty close and call the stream oh
shoot Why What oh we just got to set up
for a next one
yeah they don't show up till 12:15 right
now no worst cases you could walk out on
me and then what I was fine I just kind
of like remembered like all right I go
it's you okay you is another button that
I wasn't okay damn it I need to add him
somehow
can you go to full camera give me a full
camera real quick purple room real quick
I can get you later all right
Rach I just sent you with invites and I
am Tay I will also add a Thibet for next
time right now we got full party all
right you can switch back to the game
with pipi all right I should be able to
add mr. Roarke Thank You Network type No
all right rook can you invite oh he
Jordan mean works awesome circumvented
I'd like a look at the thing where it's
requested to join but I can't actually
do anything I could do it from here
potentially I think so you'd be
surprised you got to go into like
settings and how this app works assuming
they're not doing like maintenance on it
right now
oh god what do you mean I got a sign no
here we go I figured it out okay there
you go uh-oh you want me to make a ps4
and a PC clan that's not
and two separate clans now here we go
this week nightfall is prism and killing
ty like kill to gain time if there's
enough demand for it we could maybe do
it at which point I would make you the
ps4 and then you go PC that's Barry yeah
I would just convert our normal clan
into a does more solar does more but
right now we haven't hit a point where
there's alright so with prism elemental
damage you see it there it says solar
polarization hopefully our pip is not
it's not blocking it so Solar does more
damage you also take more damage
now it's void boy does more damage it
still shows yeah I thought I peeked over
I just want to make sure played out hit
something it did not
okay I have accepted everyone who told
well how is he's not dead that was Boyd
everything hurts so normal dude
yesterday's nightfall is so easy is like
touring which is just spam grenades
John D's saying if you want to make this
night felt easy as hell just run with
two hunters at how I feel Mike Hawk Oh
does it blow up the boss really fast
there's damage during solar box yeah
that's like when solar doesn't make
sense yeah I died there because it was
solar and the Rockets are solar and
that's always fun
I guess the Fallen version of this is
harder than whatever last week's was
game Brazil's yeah sure give you give
you a shout-out thank yourself at home
like him okay Jules is heading off
saying love loves us thanks Jules love
you too
love ya love all yeah you're all
wonderful people oh wait there's none of
them are boys suck a rocket
so yeah if you're you always want to use
kinetic when you don't have the elements
that it is telling you what does more
damage
Ravi's reasons oh what a sneaky captain
we need to grab that ball or I need to
go grab that ball I guess oh it's Ark
right now that is so bad here we go
we're doing pretty good though I guess
you start with about eleven minutes and
we're at about eleven minutes right now
so we'll see it wouldn't be a normal
GameSpot fashion if we don't have like a
real good close but clenching scared oh
yeah where we don't actually you know
who think we're gonna do it and then
it's like Oh God
are we gonna do it yes
oh hello random ass captain
we solar
sometimes you gotta learn to run alright
boy oh man this guy's ballsy Brooks
using that sort life it's the rush sure
though Oh Boyd still be boys yeah one
shot of almost one shot of ship I'm
using I always call it your devil so I
think it's better Devils it's a crucible
hand cat it's actually one of the best
yeah better Devils it's one of the best
hand PVE or could be both PvE and PvP
hand cannon sponsored crucible
you gotta from crucible packages as well
if you get one it's pretty good has its
explosive rounds well if it's gonna be a
raid that which they haven't confirmed
that it would be vex most likely because
it shows X it's a vex oriented you'll
see it looks like the last one I would
assume is fallen because it's like Siva
oriented but we're just straight running
guys right now and then we're gonna
Sparrow and then run some more in the
game so the nightfall this week is so
hard it's actually not terrible you just
have to kind of like make sure your
party has you know different types of
elemental damage and you can kind of
choose the boss by just like all doing
big damage sometimes you got to and then
you got to s just got a weave we're good
yeah and we got two seconds from killing
that side I hope the rest of my buddies
make it though is the problem because I
don't know if they need to do what I
group started he knows I don't know if
yellow Sanchez knows but I believe he'll
make it in time
and now we'll pull board how I look at
it
well the other good PvE weapon to get if
we haven't turned it in yet is nameless
midnight it is one of the by far best
Scout PvE weapons in the game the other
one that's pretty good if you've ever
gotten it from the weaponsmith is the
mañana and I'm saying that wrong but
it's like mañana and sr4 so if you have
that don't make sure not to blow that
over you're gonna want to keep that I
have no arc so good luck to these guys
when in doubt I would just kind of keep
it throwing my fault and then go later
just switch to solar really it's so
dirty I would I think I would have died
anyways cuz I took a cannon shot right
to the face but that was rather alright
thanks thanks team that's why you have a
team
there's a lot of snipers on the other
side
avoid
yeah doing good
hopes to have a 290 no feel like they're
always aiming for me but that's fine
arc
how big mercury it's gonna be as a
planet here's the thing do you think
it's how they confirmed that it's a
planet outside the social space I mean
you don't I mean like you could do some
missions but it's not actually
controlled yeah I just don't know if
like are we getting the entire planet or
is it gonna be like IO or it's just like
I don't know I have a hope I hope we get
the planet that's pretty cool cuz I
didn't expect to get a planet so shoot
the legs even though I should be
shooting their shields
oh you wonder if it's almost like a
that's when you get too old cynical rout
of life oh well they basically had it
done but then they get out there's
trials baby
the dread-nots for poultry in the main
game although that was I think they
actually just didn't have it finished
look at all that heavy we're in business
looking good - I feel like we're gonna
make it out of here and pretty pretty
good time - okay I'm jinxing it I feel
like I'm jinxing it right now that's
fine though this is this is this is the
ghost door though here this is the where
we could have we can make a sandwich
because I don't know why this door takes
forever to open curtain call is the best
non-raid rocket launcher I think it's
actually the best rocket launcher even
even if you count the raid 1 because the
clusters are tighter so it's better for
single target and I think it shoots
faster than the sins of the past for
those gears mainly Johnny
that's weird he's normally like right
there
Wow
shivery does
Orpheus Riggs is so broken that's
probably the best piece whoa celestial
Nighthawk I guess you could argue
Spencer
so no once again ask what the hand count
you're using is useful hand can you read
again of course yeah I got really lucky
it was like my first crucible package
that I turned in I was like oh I was
like please be better Devils and then I
was better that did not happen with
curtaincall though I tried real hard did
not happen turned in three packages the
bollocks told me try again another time
Bob Jones asking about the rocket oh god
what's the better rocket between what I
don't know what's the better rocket I
needs to know rock rocket help me home I
don't know I don't use rockets
oh no it's solar if you're comparing
curtain call I just I just explained it
if you're comparing those two but if
you're not oh god it's void
Oh how's like how did I not follow the
ground yet I'm like oh I landed on the
ship like I meant to yeah
Orpheus greater than Nighthawk yeah I
think at least in PvE it is oh yeah in
most cases yes the only time it would be
better to have Nighthawk he's like maybe
on like Calais or maybe on this guy just
because obviously I was really hoping it
the art when we fought the boss
look at him run alright last time we got
seven and a half that's plenty
it's Ark and by the time oh you blew a
kiss by the time we get up there it
won't be Ark which means I won't get to
do damage with my solar we don't have
any soul way right now I don't think you
can kind of some walk in with the tiny
but not really not you can kind of keep
checking in with your shoulder yeah this
is exactly the same as console first
time the same modifiers and everything
oh go yellow Sanchez no to the boss
you have your Captain America no now we
got to fight him legit wait I missed in
it right over his house yeah the way me
and Kali did it was yeah we both were
like arts yeah that's a pretty smart way
to put on I forget the name of the and
sends it yeah is it rate in flux
something like that and yeah you can
just let that go
so basically I did it and then after i-5
right now
Kalia vendetta and who's destroyed
I wish I still had that goodnight what
been nice to have that grenade for the
boss on arc but he's not gonna be art by
the time we get out of this so but or by
the time he gets out of there I got to
go grab the ball
unless words might be on it
Epis on solar bring out Auto rifle
so he's gonna jump back like right here
well he has this super good night
yeah
easy peasy plenty of could it did
racking King thanks work for helping and
yellow Sanchez I hope that helps you out
yellow what I would do is I would
potentially not turn in your milestone
till later this week just to kind of
maximize you should find out what that
exotic is though oh yeah we will we will
definitely go back to the tower we got a
new COO boy when you get rid of that
cool boy if you need a blue
Michael is pretty good this is from Ida
I'm gonna wait on Toronto okay I guess
submachine gun that's [ __ ] ah dude
that's caca yeah SMG man I need it I
need something better than that for
leveling up didn't happen the dream is
dead John Luke yeah yeah dream is dead I
didn't even noticed that that was a
performance raid someone said 7:00 p.m.
Eastern super spam for the win that's
correct
I don't know well so they're suppose to
be a patch today for consoles so maybe
it's after that patch I have no idea
normally Bungie is pretty good up like
on bungee help telling you when they're
gonna do their maintenance or usually
they tell you the day before so it's
weird that they haven't announced
anything but yeah so that was pretty
cool
didn't expect that to go so smoothly but
thank you for the help work saying his
name wrong
feel like I'm butchering close well calm
star star star lord thank star and
thanks yellow Sanchez and yeah we're
gonna go find out what this exotic is
I'm gonna be hot garbage hopefully it's
good infusion fodder have you start
getting duped
- my first exotic was a Duke it was I
think Duke's son shot I was like great
like the wing yeah cuz I already had
yeah and then I got a Duke cold heart
man and
that's kind of how it is oh but there is
gonna be a patch that's gonna address
that oh yeah where you should hopefully
get less tubes I don't know when that
patch is taking over watch hearthstone
basically Blizzard games do you have to
be a little twenty to do strikes no you
should be able to unlock that I forget
it depends on where you are in the story
but you unlock that in the story and
that that'll allow you to uh another
coup void all right take that token
sorry Oh a lot of garbage there go check
out the Brighton gram maybe we got lucky
in like a spicy Robin oh come on please
just be insta spawn it's not insta spawn
I'm just gonna blow it up damn it it's
faster than mine I guess you only want
instant spine looks cool bikes you know
we want instant spawn flakes you know
how expensive it is to freakin shader
look at that 11 K so exotic first strike
did a good job reviving me I died so
many times yellowing up there that's
those dumb all right do the purples
first garbage sometimes you get lucky
and get in exactly right now what do you
want - what do you think this is cold
heart you think cold heart because I'm
just I hope it's something useful that I
could blow up I don't even know what
that would be actually it's not even
useful it's 273 whatever or no it's 278
what what could I get that I want
there's like Oh merciless I'd be good I
really want merciless please sweet
business I have a sweet business oh you
do yeah
Master Rahul hold on kneel in front of
him please please
Rahul ooh something IV chillin swing
grats on that please merciless
Bunch I don't need I'm stupid don't have
time so I have no idea what those do
they're cool but they're they look like
Rockets cause I got jump Jets
hi what's his name from my hair academia
oh yeah
oh god it's the stupid his name but it's
the glasses guy that's the the student
council or the president of the class
what the Frick is his name forgetting
his name anyway yeah I can't man I just
wanted merciless I might get merciless
from the milestones here you know what
well well just Yolo my milestones how
about that sure I don't care I really
don't care
normally I would min/max you know me but
like it's fine it's fine I'm not I'm not
to worry about it
alright Zavala merciless merciless it's
definitely a better one it was a 286
just just burning a fire all right we
got a like two more chances I'm not
feeling good about it here we'll go
check out what that one was
I'm so sad right now it's 291 I mean you
can't complain necessarily but what's
the weapon ordinance being sold this
week I'll go now you know what we're
closer before I forget there's nothing
worse than finding a weapon order
Binford Darcy which looks kind of cool
oh it's pretty cool yeah it's pretty
cool and then I think it's risk runner
that's also cool Oh actually summer
storm Sun chart is good at least that's
true but when you have God in three when
you had a total of three Sun that's my
third son shot you don't really need
another Sun shot they're gonna add
ornaments to armor exactly yeah they're
gonna add other exotic
possibly I don't know where I just
remember hearing that somewhere right I
could be crazy here we go here we go
story okay great give me some clever all
right
fire fire uh weekly Maps though I didn't
get an exotic last week but I think
Aaron did and also space those out don't
open them right away I don't think they
fixed that yet there's a thing we're
like you can't open chests with him like
you want to wait like three to five
minutes for chest
apparently all right our last attempt
here will be at I think Hawthorne it was
really far away I technically have my
clan Ingram you know I haven't done
those I have five now though because I
saved my last week once it was
apparently stack I have my might of
course not gonna turn that in yet until
I turn these all in so I can make my
nameless midnight like as high as well
well I'm gonna turn in my my time and do
that but yeah sorry let's go come on Oh
what the hell why does she have
something what did I do for you remember
this day sure give me those tokens yeah
I don't I don't care about her at all
she gives you the the armor from the
when you originally started that's the
armor you get from nope I don't
Oh fudgsicles
alright planning grants oh yes that's
the rocket yes damage it's in the post
but you saw it that's all that matters
merciless that's just this is the worst
getting the legendary shards are now as
the worst that that was really bad well
it's okay we got the we got the rocket
that's all that matters
and that sucked no damn merciless
we got another midnight it's pretty good
yeah would've been better if it was a
curtain call but whatever it can't be
greedy and all right we got effed we did
not get any exotics but I'm just gonna
really quick to the post to show you
that rocket launcher it's real good it's
not as good curtain call as I had
mentioned but we should be closer to
like 290 light now so that's the benefit
of joining a clan though you could have
a could get some free gear for doing
nothing but being in the clan if you
want and so until we run out of space
which yeah might be pretty soon we get
Bob until tase post masters full and he
loses the stuff he wants dude there's
not 21 things in here okay once you once
you relax off that keep that that is a
thing [ __ ] get rid of that cuz just suck
all right cool I do find them slightly
more useful in the PC version because I
can aim better but they still not
preferable what sorry I grenade
launchers because I can actually the
only grenade launcher I would recommend
at all is a play of the game that's the
only one every other grenade launcher is
just is is do do you don't want it
alright so in theory we can equip that
that that but we didn't get a glove that
that's not good that
and we didn't get a mark so we're 285
now okay I'm not bad I didn't I can
toggle mods and stuff ah Eric was
playing so yeah cool there's only
putting the mask on all right guys well
that was a the weekly reset on the PC
version of destiny - we're gonna have
another stream in like 45 minutes for
some but uh I almost have Bungie guys
but Fez the guys are gonna come in and
they're gonna be showing off doom VFR
and Skyrim VR so make sure to check that
out that'd be pretty cool and then of
course we're gonna have stuff every week
I don't know if I can say what's on
Thursday but Thursday to tune in my filo
earlier Friday we got clawed scream yep
it's probably got a comment stream so
thanks shooting guys and see you next
time
oh dear
it broke